Gina had 2/3 cup cups of laundry
detergent
she used half of the detergent on Friday
to wash all of her sheets how much
detergent does she have left so we're
essentially going to take half of
two-thirds or one-half times two-thirds
so let's see which of these choices
match up so we should be taking 1/2
times two-thirds well here they're
taking two-thirds minus 1/2 so this
isn't going to be right here they're
going to be taking let's see 1/3 because
2/3 times 1/2 this is exactly what we
want to do we want to take 1/2 of 2/3
and we multiply the numerators 2 times 1
is to multiply the denominators 3 times
2 is 6
you have to 6 you could say that 2 6 has
either been used up or 2/6 is left and
2/6 is the exact same thing as 1/3
divide the numerator and the denominator
by 2 so this looks right and so here 1/6
cup well we know it's not 1/6 cup we
know it's 1/3 cup so here 1/3 cup
because 2/3 is equal to 1/3 plus 1/3
that's right so half of 2/3 must be 1/3
this is exactly right as well these are
both completely reasonable ways to
getting the right answer that gina has
1/3 she used a third of a cup of laundry
detergent and she has a third left